your new show which we said just got
picked up congratulations on that
legendary this is about this whole
culture of ballroom some people may
think they know what ballroom means but
they probably don't can you explain yes
so I think a lot of people imagine the
waltz when I think of all the room but
ballroom is actually an underground
scene that kind of nurtured young black
and Latino talent often queer and trans
folk who had been shunned from their own
personal communities and found their
kind of chosen families within the
ballroom scene and it's full of art and
fashion and music and voguing the type
of dance that people think Madonna
invented but she didn't she was paying
back then to the ballroom scene and so
we have made a dance competition about
ballroom because it's been really
frustrating to spend decades watching
mainstream pop culture borrow from
ballroom so like vernacular the way we
speak like spill the tea shade all these
different common phrases that we have in
our day-to-day language
fashion our music dance runway all of it
comes from ballroom but ballroom never
gets accredited and it never gets paid
and so we wanted to make sure that for
the first time people realize where all
of this comes from and start to
recognize the people who invented it and
so it's a cool show and it's kind of
half documentary style or half
competition and I'm really proud of it
and I'm really happy that showed that
it's so unusual in this current climate
is being picked up for a second season
and am i right the ballroom community
was really a community when it's started
out they really felt like they weren't
welcome anywhere else because they
represented the other the different
exactly like the most marginalized
people and so it's this you know all we
hear about the news life is really sad
and depressing or scary stories about
what happens that community but a
foreign community is actually full of so
much joy and love and talent and more
community than like I've ever seen in
this community it's just so open no they
feel like they have nothing to lose and
everything to give each other
I have never
ever been an environment ever like I was
shooting the show just full of she's
such a resilience and like inspiring
funny cool people I've never felt like
more of a boring stock up English in my
entire life would I stick out in the in
the barroom community be you and me in a
corner it would be you amid a corner
everyone else and sounding and looking
much cooler I am always the
fish-out-of-water wherever I go honestly
I'm on it